we're gonna show you four different kids
answering a question and you have to
decide whether they're lying or telling
the truth each kid is told that if they
get seven out of ten balls in the basket
they will be given five dollars but just
before they start the experimenter finds
an excuse to leave the room and ask them
to stand behind the line and throw the
balls into the basket one at a time so
these kids are now alone in the room so
the incentive to cheat is pretty high
but little do they know the scientists
have placed a hidden camera in the room
the question the experimenter asked when
they got back was did you cheat and here
were their answers okay could you tell
which ones were telling the truth and
which were lying try again nope okay it
turns out that kids one and two we're
telling the truth and kids three and
four were lying but in fact 80% of kids
over the age of four will lie in this
scenario when guessing who was lying the
answer was either yes or no so you had a
50% chance of getting it right so even
if you did guess correctly you're
actually not necessarily that good at
detecting lies and turns out no one
really is dr. King Lee is a lying
researcher now he is not a researcher
who lies okay he is a researcher who
studies lying
my name is Ken Lee I'm a professor at
the University of Toronto once we did
the studies with many many children
while they tell lies they look right
into your eyes they don't blink so that
that common-sense view is totally out of
the out of the way right away
studies show that across multiple
professions like judges social workers
or police officers people who would
expect are good at detecting lies turns
out they aren't okay so we are here at
Congolese developmental lab and I'm with
Sarah who's gonna help us with one of
the technologies that can detect
emotions and lying so what are we gonna
do we are going to use FAFSA which is
behind me we had already recorded you
making some interesting facial
expressions different I tried to make
different emotions okay so what are we
looking at we have my face and a bunch
of
graphs what do they mean so each of
these different colors is a different
emotion so right now we're looking at
joy there's anger surprise fear and
contempt you look great about here it
looks like you're about to experience a
little bit of disgust really I was asked
about eating toenails
how do you do this with kids and in like
a more experimental environment yeah so
this there's kind of two options you can
use this technology with one is you get
a person to sit down and watch and
record them with the webcam you can put
some stimuli on the screen see how they
react to it but that really doesn't help
us out with lying instead we want to see
how two kids or even adults lie in the
real world so we put them into real
situations where they're lying to us or
telling the truth and we secretly record
their faces and later on we can take
that video get into this plug it in
they're so cool
but what happens if someone lies with a
neutral face I mean it's not that hard
like watch this I in fact did not steal
the parts of Michael Stern the coolest
kid in my class in grade seven even
parents cannot assess accurately when
their own kids are lying but thankfully
science is here to help us out we
recently developed a new technology
called chance they're more optical
imaging technology so the idea basically
is they used literally it has a peel of
the skin like this then you see the
blood underneath your skin and then you
link up the in the frames of the videos
and then you can see the blood flow
changes in different parts of the face
and by doing so then you combine them
all together and using machine learning
again and you can detect the passions in
which the child is lying
versus the patterns in which the child
is telling the truth one of the major
features is actually when you like the
facial blood flow on the cheek goes down
but their power flow in the nose goes up
so one of the studies were wrong and we
show that about 85% accuracy we can tell
the child is lying or not lying so blood
flow to the face can help us detect if
someone is lying and hilariously blood
actually flows to your nose
hashtag Pinocchio The Lying obviously
requires your brain so how do we study
what's going on in the brain when
someone's lying so what exactly is this
even called this is our F nears machine
which is functional near-infrared
spectroscopy ooh okay as near as much
easier tune look at Lady Gaga New York
the newest hat is here so these the red
ones is emitting the light and then the
blue one is trying to measure how much
light it can receive and depending on
how much light is lost between these two
ports we can kind of determine how much
oxygen is in the blood and where the
brain is most active but turns out there
are differences in the brain so one
children are lying we discovered that in
the prefrontal cortex it's more activity
when you're lying than telling the truth
while you are lying
it takes more neural resources to do
controls and the telling the truth
requires very limited neural controls
and we discovered that there before it's
kind of well-organized synchronized and
after you have told a lie then the brain
just goes haywire so so telling a lie is
very not very good for your brain we can
definitely relate to that whenever I lie
I always panic so much and I realize I
can't hold the conversation anymore
because my brain has gone like
completely haywire but I barely ever
laugh no it's all the time every day all
day it's amazing to think though that
dr. Lee's lab has been able to look at
brains in real time as they lie and see
the chaos that ensues when you're trying
to tell a fib it's pretty fascinating to
think about the ways in which is techno
could be used I mean imagine in the next
presidential election being able to see
in real time if someone is lying or
telling the truth I mean it's pretty
powerful thing but it's got to be
perfected first so that it's not used or
abused in the wrong way thank you so
much for watching really appreciate it
make sure you subscribe to ASAP science
and let us know if there's any other
labs or things happening that you want
us to go on the scene to check out we
live in Toronto though so hopefully okay
let's say next time peace